si las reacciones son encontradas tanto
de republicanos como de demócratas los
republicanos son más de seguir apoyando
esta política de donald trump de querer
excluir a irán y seguir cosechando
enemistades con aliados divisiones
seguir con el discurso de américa
primero sin embargo los demócratas están
de acuerdo con estrechar lazos con
europa volver a esta unión para hacer
frente a las amenazas de china y de
rusia tanto antemano de ciberseguridad
como también en temas climáticos y de la
salud
cristóbal presidente joe biden también
oficializó el regreso del país al
acuerdo de parís después de que el ex
presidente tome lo retirará del pacto
que significa esta decisión para el país
más contaminante del planeta
claro y es que después de china eeuu es
el país que más contamina y con buenos
ojos recibieron este anuncio los líderes
mundiales con buenos ojos de que eeuu
vuelva al acuerdo de parís de que eeuu
quiera reducir para el 2030 sus
emisiones de gases invernaderos quiera
también empezar a trabajar con temas de
economía verde de hecho se espera que en
los próximos años el gobierno de bailén
invierta 2 billones de dólares en
cambiar la economía fósil a una economía
verde y lo dijo bien yo quedé y también
en el foro de seguridad de múnich dijo
que faltan 10 años para hacer un cambio
concreto porque esta puede ser la última
oportunidad para poder cambiar este
destino climático del mundo bueno y
además de usted lo mencionaba el
mandatario dijo que eeuu se espera
promover diálogos para reactivar el
acuerdo nuclear con irán sin embargo los
líderes de la nación islámica piden que
eeuu se levanten las sanciones impuestas
por trump
esto es posible cristóbal es posible que
eeuu retire las sanciones
sí pues además de decir que eeuu está
abierto a un diálogo con irán eeuu
también a través de un comunicado le ha
pedido a las naciones unidas que no
aplique del todo las sanciones que eeuu
y que el gobierno de donald trump trató
de impulsar contra irán y también
flexibilizó el viaje de diplomáticos
iraníes a eeuu
esto ha sido recibido obviamente pues
con buenos ojos irán dijo que está
dispuesto a reunirse también con eeuu y
esta reunión sería entre cinco miembros
del consejo de seguridad de las naciones
unidas y un representante desde irán así
como el representante de eeuu pues la
información con cristóbal bases
corresponsal de france 24 en washington